[Music]
welcome everybody it's been a while now
I know through high requests that you
guys have asked me to do another monk
bonus so what do I say
muff bog me riding the [ __ ] [ __ ]
right I used the joke again I don't give
a [ __ ] okay it was funny the first time
I'm saying it again how about you stop
motioning to when I'm doing [ __ ] alright
I'm a gesticulate ER so what [ __ ] so
what foods are we eating today
my friends we are going to be eating
three of my favorite Robins from my
favorite ramen spots in Los Angeles now
I know in a video before I did
three of my favorite instant ramen but
if you've never had that real ramen
goodness you've got to be a treat today
my friends now for those of you who
don't know Robin is that good good stick
to your ribs stick to your soul eat when
it's cold type of food and if it doesn't
have that anxious fattiness to it you
don't want to eat it so without further
ado my friends let's bring in ramen
number one chip Lau look at this one
right here this right here my friends is
my personal number one favorite ramen
spot in all of LA now I know that a lot
of people have their preferences but
this is the first one that captured my
heart and I actually didn't have this in
LA I first had it in San Diego this is
San toca ramens
spicy miso ramen with chashu now of
course it's not as pretty as it would be
if you got it from there because a lot
of the liquid actually absorbed into the
noodles because they would have
separated out for me but they still
allowed me to take it to go anyways so
you have yourself some bamboo shoots you
have your nice delicious Joshu pork and
I'm just gonna go ahead and dig into
this it's about to be poppin
Oh Oh nothing's wrong with this ramen
absolutely nothing I've eaten this ramen
probably over a hundred times and every
time I eat it it's the same reaction I
get a little chub it goes a little Boop
but my boners sound like a fart oh then
of course what you got to do take a
little Bambi Z a little noodle easy oh I
missed it I can't [ __ ] it up a little
bit of both right there get that noodle
pool action going on
[Music]
make sure what I just [ __ ] [ __ ] so
good man
it's just ramen is fatty and salty and
that's the way that it honestly should
be if your ramen isn't like bed and
you're trying to go for like a fatless
ramen you probably don't have any
friends but it's just so delicious I
mean tonkotsu broth I mean this is
actually at Uncle Joe's broth which is
made from pork bones so it's gonna have
like this cream in it there is no cream
in there but that's just when the pork
fat alone and if you can see like these
little globs of fat and the spice and
obviously some of that color from there
is from the miso that they put in it's
just like umami bombs all over the place
cuz miso already has like a deep rich
like fermented earthy flavor which is
already a new mommy bomb in and of
itself
they have wood ear fungus which is this
stuff right here bamboo shoots and of
course these delicious noodles
[Music]
you know when I've actually first had
real ramen I don't know what to expect
because I didn't really want to pay like
I don't know eight or ten bucks for
ramen it was something that was comfort
food for me that I ate growing up coming
from a package so I was like well how
much different can like handcrafted
ramen be I don't think it's gonna be
that different and when I ate it
my life was changed I just I've done
[ __ ] passed out right on the spot
just Wow ramen to me is something that I
will eat probably till the day I die
even if I'm all of them my dogs I listen
there's way too much sodium in your food
you've got to cut down they're gonna die
I don't like all right well [ __ ] it I'm
just gonna die eating ramen then and you
can't tell me what to do mister doctor
with your stupid medical degree
[Music]
mm what's the first time you guys ever
had ramen in that first experience is
always the best experience to know it's
like going on to like a travel adventure
in your mouth and you don't really have
to go anywhere it's got to go to the
restaurant like eating food that hits
that heart string it's indescribable
that's why like boom men that's why I
like homey food like this too I'm not
like too big and too like fancy food I'm
not saying there's something wrong with
it but I like food that's accessible to
a lot of people you know good portions
and it doesn't have to be like huge
portions but decent enough and you
should walk away with the foodgasm every
time and it doesn't have to be extra
pretty every time you eat it either
this will when you guys prefer to ask me
to do a milk-bone had no idea that this
is something that you guys would like
but I actually kind of enjoy it it's
kind of like um I don't know and we're
sitting across each other at a dinner
table talking but you're not saying
anything at all it's just me talking all
the damn time
[Music]
and right here towards the very end this
is going to be the best part so we just
have a little bit of noodle left or
you're hoping there's more and you're
just all that salty fatty goodness if
you want to know where this is at this
is towards the west side of LA is
actually in a in a market called Mitsuwa
needs to watch supermarket is a Japanese
chain you'll see other restaurants in
there but you'll notice this little
robbing spot right in the corner they
are cash only so make sure that you
bring cash if you want to get it there's
a ATM inside but bring it before so
you'd have to pay that surcharge next up
this is going to be a little different
here this is from the very famous sugita
in l.a suji toss specialty is not
actually the regular ramen that you
typically see with the egg noodle in the
broth we're talking about dipping ramen
a lot of people probably haven't had
dipping ramen if they haven't even had
the regular ramen in the first place but
dipping ramen is on a whole nother level
now sugita is known for this right here
this delicious dipping broth it's that
same type of like tonkatsu super porky
fattiness but it's kind of broken down
even more and it's a lot more thicker
and it's just made to grip onto these
starchy noodles when you grab a bite out
of it
now inside this delicious pork claw
penis or other pieces of pork and pork
fat and of course you have your
marinated Japanese soft boiled egg and
over here with these delicious noodles
you have your fatty chashu pork and the
killer here is this lime you're not
gonna put this line into here you're
actually gonna put it on your noodles
because with every bite you want that
limey acidity with this fatty goodness
so I'm gonna start with that
I'm getting horny off my food yeah two
lines right there then you're gonna go
for the third line because you can't get
enough limes and if you ever go to
Sujit ah on the west side make sure that
you ask for extra limes
if you like that goodness and if it's
right on your fingers just put it right
back on there anyways it's all good and
before I even take a piece of that fat
chashu pork what I'm going to do
oops just dip it right in here there's
all that lime on it
and see what that does with those
starchy noodles and that thick thick
broth it's just like that oh my
[Music]
[ __ ] spilling everywhere I don't even
care hey napkin let me wipe this down
real quick cuz I'm being a bit of a slob
but man holy crap I'm talking about all
right
I could've just done it myself but I
don't know why you took it for me cuz I
was gonna put it right there and then
you took it for me to throw it in there
that's pretty [ __ ] dumb anyways
though the flavor profile that you're
getting on this by the way it's pork and
it's also a little bit of fish because
it has that smoky I'm almost 100% sure
they put a lot of like bonito flakes in
here or something because it has that
smoky fishy taste that you do get from
bonito with the next bite we're gonna
add a little bit of that chashu pork I'm
gonna dip it right into this mofo so
when I take the noodles and I put it in
there I'm gonna grab it up with all that
sauce sauce boss
ooh it's okay to play with your noodles
too by the way yeah that kind of came
out like playing with your dick mmm next
bite with a fatty piece of Joshu and if
you're looking to lose weight and you
want low carb low fat [ __ ] this is not
for you
[Music]
hmm and what I like to do with the third
bite my friends is this part right here
with this tonight let me just slice this
open for you guys so you guys can see
what how delicious this is do you see
that do you see the yolk mixing in with
that crazy pork fat third bite is always
the best bite because I've already
experienced everything that I wanted out
of the protein the the pork now I'm
gonna get what I want out of this egg
take this dip it in and just to show you
once again that delicious pull of flavor
like that yes take a bite of this first
[Music]
then I buy that egg then I'm in heaven
man that marinated soft-boiled like aid
always does it for me man because I know
like we're used to like soft-boiled eggs
just being straight-up hard-boiled or
we're not hard blood but just the white
egg that you normally have when you have
this it's just flavor everywhere and
that salt actually cures that yolk and
it makes it really goopy and gooey like
this oh man
[Music]
you know I have a friend a friend
actually used to date her but she uh she
really really loved this place and she
would just non-stop talk about this
place and I think she was probably the
reason why I even fell in love with this
place in the first place but it's single
enough
I kept the place but I left her mood is
sometimes more important than women I
say about 90% time is more important
than your partner I don't give a [ __ ]
what you say I'm not saying Muriel but
any girl before I met her that's not
it's not not saying Muriel I'm not
saying Muriel any girl that I met before
her if they said listen either start for
a week or be with me I'd be like peace
out [ __ ] pack up your [ __ ] and get the
[ __ ] out my house [ __ ] tell me if I
should love you or love food you must be
out your goddamn mind which is damn
kitties I got my own city to play with
I'll need your titties [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I'll take my dick slide it right back to
the ass crack bandit a [ __ ] to take
your friends to this place Sawtelle and
Los Angeles has a lot of Japanese food
there too it's definitely a place to
visit if you go to Suzy Tyler there's
going to be a huge weight there if you
go during busy times
that's just how well-known it is that's
how much people like it another string
of that noodles put it back in that
sauce bring that [ __ ] egg pull
right up to my [ __ ] face and
see I cradled it within the noodles to
protect it from me
[Music]
mmm so freakin good stick-to-your-ribs
bust you in the gut
making forget your children slap your
mama in the face Tiger dick to your
belly button pop a boner in the [ __ ]
morning and rip that [ __ ] off off the
bellies of your hair [ __ ] good I'm not
gonna be able to finish this I'm not
gonna even lie I don't know how those
skinny little Japanese and Korean girls
eat this much goddamn food they're
[ __ ] Duke you must be insane but we're
gonna move to the next one which is a
new rama spot out in LA that's doing
something different that I didn't think
that I would like as much as I did but I
have to feature it because it's probably
a place that I go to more then i go to
san toga because Sontag was actually far
from where i live the new contender in
all of Los Angeles
rock on rock on with the are in with the
are so the ramen that I got to show you
guys is one that they do very unique so
the cool thing about this place is when
you walk by it it kind of shows you like
or maybe it was inside the restaurant
there's like a little chart that shows
you how the chef who created this Robin
gets his flavor profiles or his like
umami bond as I call it a lot of the
broth here are actually vegetarian a
majority of them actually are and he has
vegan options now first when I heard
about that [ __ ] I was like vegan ramen
get the [ __ ] out of here dude you're a
[ __ ] loser I'm gonna punch you in the
face and drag you outside and then piss
you right [ __ ] surprisingly I decided to
give it a chance because you know you
can't really judge a ramen by its cover
so I walked in and I got this chicken
potage ramen the broth apparently is
vegetarian the chicken is what makes it
not vegetarian so the potage if you've
ever had a potage soup it's like a corn
potato type of puree or some type of
thick soup that you had but he did that
with his ramen so what that kind of does
with this it gives it this creamy flavor
without having like animal fat inside it
which is that you get from tonkatsu and
instead of using animal fat on top he
actually uses olive oil so
[Music]
Ramin my friends something about it
gets me right into my souls right into
my [ __ ] not these ramen noodles are a
little thinner than most dice little
delicious onions bamboo shoots and of
course what I like to add to mine is a
little bit of their house chili oil this
stuff by the way is pretty damn spicy so
if you don't like spicy food you're not
gonna like this but the flavor that
comes from this is out of this world so
I'd like to use it right off the bat
just to give you guys what I'm going
through right now this is way lighter
than the other ramens that I had now
that's what I love about this ramen you
get the flavor without that crazy heavy
animal fat that you're so used to
getting in ramen now I know I said
earlier if it's not fatty if it's not
unctuous it's not gonna be delicious but
this man proved me wrong when he created
this ramen it was actually so damn good
that I I think Jo and I ate at this
place three or four times a week because
it's very reminiscent even though it's
different from the normal like
traditional ramen that you get of what
you can get in Japan no joke if you go
to like these small little joints out of
nowhere that doesn't have a sign and you
kind of walk in this is the type of
ramen that you're gonna get very clean
on the palate super just not overly
crazy with their flavors just very
simple and straightforward and man
if you can make ramen this flavorful
without making me feel like a piece of
[ __ ] then you did your job right this
tender piece of chicken right here so
freaking good ma'am like I said don't
get deterred by the vegan vegetarian
stuff wine I know a lot of you people
who are Pro meat which I am too it
doesn't mean that I don't like vegan or
vegetarian food I actually love being a
vegetarian food is just not something
that I want to eat all the time
you have another bite of this hmm this
is it man I don't even know they had to
go stuff I'm gonna get this to go all
the time it's a broth so flavorful this
is what's up man make sure that you
check this place out this is a it sucks
too because when I first came here they
were empty as health because nobody knew
who they were and I was just eating
there all the time but lo and behold
of course when something's amazing in a
chef does a great job they're going to
get popular and this place is popping
now and now I can never get a seat but
whatever
how dare he make money
[Music]
so good look at that egg ramen bite mmm
this is probably gonna be the last bite
it's so crazy I would just I was so full
but that's what I'm talking about how
light this ramen is you'll just demolish
it
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
three of my favorite ramen places in LA
mukbang completed I hope you guys enjoy
this let me know what other foods that
you want me to eat or try out or show
you that I like to eat in LA I'm
thinking about showing you guys my
favorite favorite chicken wings in LA
and now my radio chicken wings either
I'm talking about Korean chicken wings
by the way but let me know in the
comments below what other foods would
you like me to eat make create let me
know people this is a family type of
thing I missed you guys now excuse me
it's like I've put my finger down my
throne throw up in the toilet
[Music]